hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're in
game four of the 2021 world chess
championships being held in dubai
between the defending champion magnus
carlson and the challenger yana nepo now
a fun fact or
a sobering reminder of how classical
chess can be sometimes magnus carlsen
has not won
a classical game in the world
championships since 2016 five years now
they usually
hold the world championships every two
years has been three years since the
last one in 2018 2018 remember they
played
12 games and they drew every single one
of those games now they did go on to tie
breakers and magnus crosston won that he
hasn't won a classical game
in five years in the world championships
that is so he has the white pieces today
game number four there's been three
draws so far we'll see if magnus carlson
can break through and get a victory or
if we have another draw or if nepo with
the black pieces can get a victory and
start to spice things up so start out
with e4
e5 knight f3 and then nepo plays knight
f6 getting into the petrov defense
magnus carlson plays knight takes on e5
and now yonepo has an opportunity for a
boom in
chess history
millions of players would play
stories books would be written if he
played knight to c6 this
the stafford gambit here
would be incredible can he actually do
it i would name my next child
after him if he did this
he decides not to he decides to play the
main line and that's just d6 taking all
the fun out of it and the knight just
comes back here to
f3 and the players continue down the
main line knight takes here on e4
pawn two d4 pawn to d5 just solidifying
this outpost here on
e4 bishop here to d3
bishop here to d6 and typically in the
the main variation uh this outpost is
pretty annoying for white so he'll look
at things like pawn to c4
just to break up this pawn on d5 that's
protecting it castle on the king side
and then bring the rook over here to e1
just more material attacking this knight
so that white can get it off the board
if that doesn't work he can always bring
his knight here to c3
to exchange off the knights
so magnus carlsen continues by castling
on the king side castle for nepo as well
c4 as we talked about c6 just says hey
if you want to exchange i can just
replace that with my own pawn here rook
to e1 bishop down to f5 adding another
layer of protection on this e4 square
usually a big
point of focus in the petrov defense in
the main line at least queen 2 b3 always
want to be looking to get your piece
involved into the action you always want
to be thinking about where your opponent
left some material or a defense behind
the bishop on c8 as soon as it came on
line here with f5 it left behind this
pawn here on a b7 so madness carlson
getting his queen involved into the
action controlling these central light
squares also attacking this pawn here on
b7 so black queen two d7 getting
involved into the action uh defending
this bishop right here but more
importantly right away defending the
pawn here on
b7 so since none of those options were
for magnus carlsen to
remove this knight here on e4 doesn't
want to just give up his bishop right
away for it not a good trade then your
opponent would have the bishop pair
decide to go ahead and
go with his last option that is knight
to c3 so we do have the exchange right
here now the bishops come off the board
queen takes on f5 pawn takes here on c3
and then after b6 since the queen is no
longer defending this pawn here on v6 or
on b7 excuse me uh
that allows just some solid protection
here so the queen can't come up and
threaten this rook here on
a8 because the knight can't easily come
here to c6 doesn't necessarily want to
bring it to some other squares like at
d7 right now he doesn't have any great
outpost options for that so after b6
here magnus carlson decides to go and
get rid of his double pawns here on the
c file
and now we see pawn take on d5 and then
queen up to b5 so quite a bit of
exchanging on the board madness carlson
in previous games has done everything he
can to hold on to the bishop pair and
this game decides that's not going to be
an option queen up 2
b5 really is attacking the square here
on e8 uh he does have the threat of
bringing his rook up to e8 uh with the
protection from the queen right here uh
black decides to go ahead and bring his
queen to d7
to defend against that
now
you know players that don't have the
skill level as these players they might
look at this as a trap
just because okay all of a sudden i can
just take this free pawn here on d5 but
obviously that would be a huge mistake
because after the queen takes here then
bishop down to h2 check and then the
queen is going to fall so after the
knight takes here on h2 queen takes here
on d5 this would be a disaster magnus
carlson would lose the game
shocking to no one
magnus carlson does not fall for this
simple
trap here instead he plays the move pawn
to a4
now nopo's in an interesting spot here
if you trade off the queens it's
definitely going to be more of a
drawlish game but if he doesn't he could
put himself in a pretty awkward spot
here as far as how he really continues
uh he decides to go for the option of
just taking the
queen here on
b5 you know he could try something like
rook to d8 uh i don't necessarily know
that he wants to bring his rook here to
88 and just protect it
so he decides to go for the more
drawlish line uh but probably the more
correct line and that is queen takes
here on b5 pawn takes here and then pawn
a5 so this opens up an opportunity for
an opposing i think this is probably the
best move from madness carlson as well
uh for newer chess players it may look a
little odd but the pond can actually
take here on a6 for ambassador he only
has one move and one move only that he
can do that madness crossing doesn't
like that option he decides to go with
knight to h4 looking for an attack on
the king side the board we see black
play pawn to g6 i think this is pretty
straightforward just limiting the
squares where the knight can go to
knight really eyeing this f5 square
right now uh so the only real options
that magnus carlsen has is to bring his
knight back here to f3 which there's no
reason that he would ever play h4 if
that was his thought and the other
option is to push forward with his pawn
here to g4 so he can swing his
knight back here to g2 and then if it
wants to come to
f4
or e3 he has those options so g4 is the
move knight over here to d7 knight to g2
and then rook to c8 and black had a
couple options here uh he could have
easily played knight to f6 uh so i i
like this option uh his other option is
just to play uh the rook to c8 attacking
this backward pawn here on c3 this is
also a semi-open file you always want to
put your rooks on semi-open files so he
does off opt for this option now bishop
to f4 we do see the exchange here on f4
knight takes on f4
row comes down takes this pawn here on
c3
knight takes the pawn here on d5 so
really both sides just
exchanging material here rook two d3
attacking the pawn and this is an
interesting spot for white i think
there's one clear move that white has
madness crossing finds this move but i'm
curious go ahead and pause it and see if
you can find
white's next best move
so it does have the option of just
playing something like rook 2 a4
defending this pawn here on d4 but
instead i like what magnus carlsen found
and it's rook to e7 you really got to
think about your opponent's pieces uh
and how you can remove them from the
game as much as possible this knight
here on d7
it can't come to
c5 or
e5 because of the pawn here on d4
can't come to f6 it would just fall to
this knight here and it can't come to b6
it's being
you know blocked by its own pawn here
and it doesn't want to come back to b8
because it's you know then be blocking
its own rook here so the only option is
f8 and so this does a good job of
forcing the knight to move back and then
he can always still defend the pawn
right now but now this limits the
squares that nepo has as far as getting
his knight involved into the game a
night on f8 is not doing anything at all
so magnus carlsen definitely has a
pretty good setup here even though it's
going to be difficult to turn this into
a victory because his game plan is clear
he has a pass pawn here on the d file he
needs to push this up nepo just needs to
hold on he also has a pass pawn of his
own here on the a file if he can push
that that's his way to victory as well
so knight to f6 check
king 2
uh g7 wants to make sure he doesn't just
play king 2 h8 and just let this pawn
fall here on f7 so that's not going to
happen knight 2 e8 check king comes back
here pawn to d4 d5 as we talked about
his only option is to push that
pawn to a4
knight to f6
obviously would be a disaster if the
rook took
because then just knight two
f6 check and that would fork the rook
right here so uh while it may look like
yeah minus carlson's just going to lose
this pawn he is not going to so pawn 2
a4 at least not yet so knight 2 f6
the king moves
g5 so now defending this knight here on
f6 we see the pawn push forward here to
a3 it almost now looks like nepo has the
best possibility to push this pawn
forward i think madness carlson realized
this the same thing knight to e8
and now we see
uh a two-fold repetition and then both
sides decide to draw madness carlson
tried his best realized there was no way
for him to push this pawn saw the threat
here on a3 and realized this is not
going to end well as soon as the pawn
comes down here to a two the nepo has
the move rook to
d1 and then after the rook takes he can
just promote down here to
a1 and then he has the support from the
rook so that would not end up well for
madness cross and decide the i'll just
go ahead and take the draw
and so after four games five years still
going madness carlson does not have a
win in classical chess in the world
championships
but it was still an entertaining game i
thought we were going to see something
magical with the petrov defense maybe
the stafford gambit obviously i wasn't
fully expecting that but oh my gosh
would it have been exciting nepa would
have been my favorite player of all time
also would have just spiced up this
world championship a little bit so we
will be back tomorrow for game number
five and then we take a break remember
they're on three days take a break two
days on take a break and then go and
repeat that same process as well so
thank you guys so much for watching i
know many of you are looking for the
wins i am too
but i am just the messenger have to
report the games as they take place so
thanks for watching i'll see you guys in
the next video
you